.
NGTHE CNN EXIVNTINSOCE
ATTOAG
FRESHMAN.R IN COURT TT'
ISE ORR US.
O
E KNOW
>> WE T KNOW THE EXACT
NATU OF THE GEE HAVE BEEN FID
THAT'S THE COUAL COUN RI
SDOSWHICH IS IN QUEENS AND
LONG ISL
WE KNOW HE'SECTED TO APPEAR
IN FEDERAL COURT THEROW.ON AMOR
THE EASTERN DISTRICT OF NEW
YORK.
W THE CHARGES.
WEW THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT PU P
THE FBI,SECUTORS THE IN
BROOKLYN, HAVE BEEN OFN
INVESTIGATING THCOSSF AL
CAMPAIGN FINANCE FILINGS.
ABLE TO E MORE LIGHT OWHEN WE S
YOU TALKED ABOUT MANY TI GRAM
HEK  JANUARY.ONS COME TO
LIGHNUMBER
LIES HE'LDRT OF TH PRIOR
I WILL RESIT THEM.
CLCLRESUE WORKED AT GOLDMAN
SACHS AND ZIT ITY BANK.
SAID HE WAS A STAR VOLLEYBALL
PL IERE HE GOT A
NONE OF THOSE IN.
HE HAD JMETHIN HBEENWN
REAL.HE CONGMA
HE'S NOTN CHARGED WITH
ANYTHING.
WE DIDT TO A FRAUD CHARG
BRAZIL SOMER OF YEARS AGO.
>>LIO UCH YOU HAVE TTO BE KNOWNI
WHIC.
BUT LYING TO THEUBLIC IS NOT
NEF THALLEGATIONS WE'RE
G ABOUT AREN'TE
HAS SANTOSL TEAMEXISTS, REDER
OUT TO G
ERTERNOON. DECLINED TOOM.
HE SAID HE'S NOT GOING TO
ONF ES
ALLEGATIONS UNTIL HE S F DID OUC
ANHE W
HALLS EARLIE
HE DID NOT TELL US AIN HIS P AT
EXPECT HE'S GOING TO BE ABLE TE
CT>> LET'SN
ION
ON CAPITOL HILL BEFORE THE HSEC
RATHOO
GENERALLY SPEAKING.
THIS SEEMS MORE SIGNIFIC
NIT W
HOTHE SPEAKER,
RESPONDS TO THIS.
FOSOME TIME, HE'S NOED SA IF SA
UP A SPECIAL ECT THE
RIT JOE BIDEN RRME T T
LAZE SORT-THIN MAJY, THEY SAID .
POINTED TO ONE WHERE YOU WILL
POND TO GEORGE SANTOS SAYING LE
WE KNOW THHI
TO BE SEEN.EE TO REACHANY SORTFI
NOW THE
THE QUESTION WBE CHA LEARSWHETH
CA FOR GEORGNTOS TO
RESIIN THEE THAT IF
UTOMATICALLY
LOIR COMEEGNMENTS.
EARLIEEAVOROM S TEASS AF
DISCUSSIERTAIN WHETHER SS N COU.
DOUNCE A FEW WEEKS AGO
LAEDN
LEADERS ANALISTIITE TION FRORE
WOULD TRY TOINHIHAT CHANGE HD
NOW THAT HE HAS  INDD.LSO THE
BIG QUESTION FOR THE SPEAKER,
ATO ABOUT THIS CONTRO, WHO HAS
BEENIN
CONFERENCE.
SOMEW HIS RI I
SPEAKER'S
MIDAHIQUES.INHOW SERIOUS OF CAS
>> THAT WILL BE THE BIG
THING WE FIND OUT TOOWK AT THIS.
IMPORTANT TO UT'S T A CRIME TO .
IT'S NOCKGROUND.AT IS A CRIME I
YOUR FEDERAL ECTFIT U'
REPORTING SANTOSEDENDITUFOR $19
O TA
SUSPICIOUS.
SO I WOULD BE LOIN
SORT OAL FALSE STATEMENT
CHARGE HERE.
WE'RSPECULG.
>>AU JNI US AG
WITH ANOTHER LYING
POLITIC
Y COURT WHEN SAOS APEERE>> WE'
THIS.
IF IT'ED, WHETHER IT'S
A JUDGE COULD KNOW ABOUT AN HAT
ETHER THIS
INDICTMENT TO INCLUDE MO ON.YOUN
A GRAND JURBE C ABOUD JURY TES.
EMPANELLEDN THIS PARTICULAR
MATTER, WE'LL LEARN  ABOUTISS
BUT AS LEVEL ELLIE ARTICULATED
WHAT WE KNOW TO BE FOR THE STIGR
ABOUT WHETHE AND E ACTU
SERVED F ELECTORATE,
O BE THE KEYOR
ANY  FINANCE OR
ELECTION-RELATED MATTER.NO RD D
LECT A CANDIDATE
ING BASED ON THEIR.-RVERY SERIO
BEE WEANY AND
TY AND T AHAVING SOMEONEOU WANT
OFFICE.
O SAY ULD DO AUT.
TRYING TO KICK THE CAN DOWN THE
O SUGG IF THE CRIMATD,N
THEY WOULDAKACTION
WELLIFBEGINS TO
CRE THIS ACTUALLY ES
MANIFEST POLAL REAN SAIDF N OPE
CONGRESS.GITE ODD IN TS W
HI KNOW N SANTOS S
S AS THI
PROCEEDS?
ERSS IF HE'S
>> HE CAN.
THE AY TRID OF A
MEMBER OF THE U.S. CONGRESS, T
HOUSD IS BY
THAT BODY.YOU'VEO SERED DEMO DL
OF THE U.S. HOUSE EVER EXPELD I.
R THE CIVIL WAR.ATES
THE FOURTHAS
PENNSYLVANIA FROM OUE A,
A E .
WHO HAD BEEN CF
CRIME.
SO
QUESTION HFOR PU
EPTIL SEE RRE
SAOSEEN INDICTED, E
YOTO ALLOW HIM TO KE
>> WHO IS THE ONHE AREA?
>>HAELS K IT WASE NAME
>> THAT